- [Narrator] The Bank of
England may have been busy
printing money with King
Charles III's face on it,
but little is known about
how much money he makes
or how much he's worth.
He's inherited land,
properties and other items
from Queen Elizabeth II,
and one estimate suggests his
fortune is some $745 million.
But a lack of transparency from the royals
makes it difficult to determine
exactly how rich Charles is.
Here's what we do know
about his sources of income
and what it all adds up to.
Charles has always had
something of an entrepreneurial spirit.
In 1990, he launched his
Duchy Originals range
of organic oat biscuits,
which later expanded to other products
made on the prince's estate.
Those products were eventually sold
exclusively in British
supermarket Waitrose
as part of a partnership deal.
The brand reported profits
of over $4 million last year,
all of which was donated
to the Prince of Wales's
charitable foundation.
As the Prince of Wales
and heir to the throne
Charles also controlled
the Duchy of Cornwall,
an estate with net assets of 1.3 billion,
which covers almost 130,000
acres of land across England.
Its net assets have increased
in value by 44% since 2012,
with Charles seeing his
income from the estate
increase 25% over the past decade.
He raked in $28.3 million
last year, mostly through rent
from commercial and
residential properties.
Now that Charles is king,
the Duchy of Cornwall,
along with its multimillion dollar income,
goes to his eldest son, William.
- He succeeds me as Duke of Cornwall
and takes on the responsibilities
for the Duchy of Cornwall
which I have undertaken
for more than five decades.
- [Narrator] But that hardly
leaves the king destitute.
Charles inherited the Duchy
of Lancaster from his mother,
worth around $800 million.
It consists of more than 45,000 acres
of commercial, agricultural
and residential properties
in England and Wales
and provides a private
income for the monarch.
The late queen earned $29.7
million from it last year,
and there's nothing to suggest
her son won't take home a similar amount.
He also doesn't have to pay
any taxes on Duchy revenue,
though he will follow
in the queen's footsteps
and opt to pay income tax
after deducting money
spent on official duties.
But the Duchy of Lancaster
isn't the monarch's only source of income,
or even their most valuable.
A large amount of King Charles's income
derives from something
called the Sovereign Grant.
Here's how that works.
In the 1700s, the monarchy
handed over revenues
from swaths of land to the government
known as the Crown Estate.
These days, the Crown Estate makes money
on a range of assets from
retail property to golf courses
and even offshore wind farms.
Those assets are valued
at around $20 billion.
- I take this opportunity
to continue the tradition
of surrendering the hereditary revenues,
including the Crown Estate,
to my government for the benefit of all
in return for the Sovereign Grant.
- [Narrator] Every year
the government pays
a percentage of the profits
made on those assets
back to the monarchy.
Last year, it totaled
more than $106 million.
That was used to fund the
queen's official duties
and maintain royal residencies,
including Buckingham Palace,
which is kept in a trust
for the reigning monarch.
The king does not personally
own the properties
making up the Crown Estate
and can't sell them for
his own financial gain,
unlike the two properties
we know he inherited from his mother,
Sandringham House in Norfolk
and Balmoral Castle in Scotland
which has been in the
royal family since 1852.
- [Reporter] The 80,000 acre preserve
in the Scottish Highlands
has since been the holiday retreat
for Britain's ruling families.
(happy music)
- [Narrator] The two estates passed
from monarch to monarch
until Edward VIII's abdication in 1936
when a financial settlement
saw them transferred to his brother
and Charles's grandfather George VI.
Each is valued between $66 and $79 million
by one royal expert,
although a potential market
price for this kind of asset
is difficult to determine.
Last year, a cottage on
the Sandringham Estate
was made available on Airbnb
as a holiday rental by Norfolk Hideaways.
Visitors can book the Garden House
for just over $1,000 per night.
Norfolk Hideaways couldn't say
how much of any revenue from the listing
went back to the royal family.
The Balmoral Estate in Scotland
also rents out cottages
in addition to selling ticketed tours.
The king could also have inherited
Queen Elizabeth's personal
investment portfolio,
the value of which is undisclosed.
The palace won't comment
on the monarch's wealth
or the contents of wills.
They say it's a private matter.
We do know that Charles
paid no inheritance tax
on any of the assets
passed to him by the queen.
But unlike other UK citizens,
royal family members don't have
to make their wills public.
This means we can't determine
what Charles inherited from his mother
or father Prince Philip,
so we may never know
what he's truly worth.